a commonly reported symptom of clinical
depression is a warped sense of time
everything can feel like it's moving in
super slow motion
in fact depression warps everything
around it like a star warps space-time
not only your sense of duration but also
your sense of yourself and others your
mental life is thrown out of all
proportion in his film melancholia Lars
von Trier uses skewed proportions to
communicate a feeling that he's
intimately familiar with you know when I
write I can only write about myself and
and this is more or less a description
of my own depression the very first
scene after the slow-motion montage that
speaking of warp time shows both the end
of the film and the end of the world is
the newly married Justine and Michael
trying to get from the ceremony to the
reception in a stretch limo that is
almost comically too large for the
country road that they're driving on
eventually they have to abandon the car
and walk and by the time they get to the
castle where the reception is half of
the night has already been wasted what's
interesting is that the viewer doesn't
really feel that lateness we're only at
the beginning of the film and this I
think gives us a hint of the weird
almost dreamlike temporal quality of the
wedding reception to come one thing that
keeps getting stranger and stranger to
me as i rewatch the film is the
relationship between Justine and Michael
I mean at times it almost seems as if
they don't even know each other
Michael seems to be completely unaware
of the severity of Justine's depression
and there are a few shots where Michael
just stares off blankly like a kind of
dead puppet here again things are skewed
von Trier doesn't give us a sense of the
couple's past but I'm getting ahead of
myself
the first half of the film is made up of
the wedding reception alternating
between the party and Justine's
various exits as she falls deeper and
deeper into an oncoming bout of
depression von trier uses the reception
itself to set up an expectation of
continuous time but Justine's exits make
this problematic the two parts of the
sequence don't seem to fit together
justine rides off in a golf cart all the
way across the ground she language
is in a bath but the party is always
there always still happening when she
returns to it in moods that are
increasingly detached even within the
party time jumps forward at the whim of
von trier disorienting editing the film
critic Marta Figaro it's drew my
attention to the fact that for example
the newlyweds first dance is actually a
montage of Justine dancing with a number
of people all the song underneath it la
Bamba plays continuously what all this
adds up to is an unsettling feeling of
subjectivity a feeling that you're in
the head of Justine and by extension von
Trier whose attempts to get a handle on
things to lock everything in place are
upset and then finally dashed no one in
the film seems capable of measuring
things correctly whether it's the number
of beans in a jar
two million and six peas or the correct
trajectory of a rope planet everything
that's handled burns creases or shatters
and we ought to mentioned the several
artistic references von Trier makes in
the film many of which are in the very
first sequence the most obvious is this
shot which cites John Everett Millais
painting Oh philia after the character
in Shakespeare's Hamlet who is perhaps
the most famous depressive in all of
literature then we have an actual shot
of Roy goals hunters in the snow a
painting of hunters coming back to their
village empty-handed which calls to mind
another science fiction film concerned
with the deaths of the sole andrei
tarkovsky 'he's Solaris the von Trier is
a massive fan of Tarkovsky and there are
other similarities here to solarz for
example makes great use of Bach's choral
Prelude in F minor repeating it
throughout the film and as he's written
dark offski likes to use music as a
refrain the refrain brings us back to
our first experience of entering the
poetic world making it the mediate and
at the same time renewing it von trier
uses the same technique in melancholia
with vogner's prelude to Tristan and his
old a romantic song that speaks to how
the filmmaker mixes his meditation on
depression with beauty like a glowing
blue planet and desire and there are
plenty of other references to like those
to Alain Renee's last year at Marienbad
another
with a dreamlike narrative structure and
of course these early shots jumped
forward to reference but not exactly
replicate later moments in the film
melancholia is no doubt a polarizing
film its beauty is undeniable but I'm
sure many will argue that it lacks
coherence or focus indeed I have my own
problems with the second part of the
film but this is one of the most
striking portrayals to me of a disease
that affects so many but which is still
so little understood in my view
depression is what happens when your
identity that sense of the relationship
you have with the world around you
becomes untethered and focused in this
process everything starts to skew time
slows to a standstill your body wants so
easy to move feels like it weighs a ton
for a person memories start to become
disorganized the memories of a film on
the other hand are all those works of
art that inform and proceeded perhaps
this is why von trier surrounds his
characters with so many by the time we
get to the second half of the film an
extraordinary situation the approach of
the rogue planet melancholia warps even
the characters dispositions Justine
emerging slowly from the depths of her
illness reacts to the existential
situation with calm they don't need to
create Claire on the other hand her
scene other half begins to panic the
film in the end takes on the disease of
its main character I for one am happy to
see a film so earnest about sadness as
it stands science and medicine have come
up short and their apprehension of
mental illness so maybe we ought to look
to art for insights and solidarity about
what it's like living a life out of
proportion
hey everybody thanks for watching sorry
this video is a little bit late I had a
horrible stomach flu yesterday that was
just destroying me but I feel much
better now and I love this film you know
I have certain problems with it but I
think there's so much of value here and
I love the opportunity to talk about
depression and mental illness through
the lens of a film like this so I hope
you guys liked it if you want to apply
to this channel you can go right here
and pledge a dollar or three dollars per
video on my patreon page everything
helps you guys have been amazing thank
you for watching my Q&A last week that
was a lot of fun I'll definitely do more
and I will see you guys next Wednesday